it's siete seven times you know check me
out on the boulet kev show let's go
welcome to the bootleg cab podcast we
have got siete on the show nice [ __ ]
girl and i'd like to point out how much
of a professional smoker you are because
you have a lighter
attachment to your pants yeah pull that
out let's show everybody just in case
so nobody could [ __ ] take your
lighter [ __ ] be stealing
i can't comment on that
people would be still people be still
for sure
people be stealing so
when you be like hey you alerted bro
yeah
so you were talking about how you like
to wrap your back wood you put the paper
over the back wood so you'll take a
regular rolling paper like a zigzag or
whatever and paper you put it over the
backwood what's the purpose of that for
people who who weren't privy to our
combo um
it makes it burn very very slow you feel
me people that like to smoke like they
blunts lasting long you feel me
roll roll the paper over the over the
back wood
they don't hurt the charr what did you
discover this this feels like a
this feels like weed science [ __ ] right
here
i just got it from the homie petty petty
shout out to my boy petty
he was smoking a fat ass backward one
day
he wrote a paper over that [ __ ] and it
was just burning slow as [ __ ] is that
why they do in new york they do the
grabba leaf they'll like cut it up put
it in the joint it's a spliff
is that why they do it
yeah that too
that to edit in like when you roll it in
the paper over the blood it makes it hit
like that like it's a split
that stop grab a grab that tray so he's
got something to put his ashes smokes
real good yeah just literally whatever's
over there yep
there you go buddy
thank you sir
yeah
i just i'm i just like pre-rolls
just give it to me already ready just
light it up keep it rolling cool but
don't really get me high like that if
you gave me a million dollars i wouldn't
be able to roll my own [ __ ] what are you
on pre-roll oh yeah no i couldn't roll
like like i could roll a backwood i
couldn't roll a joint nothing i have to
just if i'm gonna roll something it's
the cone where you just [ __ ] joint
i couldn't even work one of those i've
tried it all you gotta do is put the
weed in it put the paper over it
that's just gonna be like you just get
the cone you stuff the weed in
oh i don't know
a little twist
back in the days my og's from compton
they um
they used to take the swisher sweet and
like you know how people used to break
it down like this like split it down the
middle right they just take the tobacco
out and just stuff the weed
well they got those now too
like the blunts badass swisher right
damn i like blunts i think backwards my
least favorite way to smoke really i
always get wheat in my mouth these are
grabba leaves i like grabbing yourself
the gravy what's the difference
backwoods is [ __ ] harsh
so this is like a different
it's a smoke it's more smoother you got
a sponsorship no they should have
sponsored me not yet
uh so for people who don't know man
where are you from you're from compton
right yeah i've copted california the
west side to be exaggerated central
um i've been following you for a minute
but uh
your [ __ ] instagram got deleted what
happened there
i don't know man instagram i said let me
get my [ __ ] back yeah cause i was like
looking for your page and
i was like yo i know i'm following this
guy this [ __ ] should just pop up i said
i've violated the terms but i'm not
violating the terms i'm just grinding
just trying to put this work out for my
fans people that's tapped in tuned in
i didn't do anything
so like do you kind of know
that you have an idea of what might have
been the violations
uh
nah i was just
on instagram one day and uh
just logged me out like it just logged
me out it said
when it logged me out it said
excuse me
i said you're suspended
so i'm reading i'm like what am i
suspended for filing the terms
i
yeah i got flagged for bullying
yesterday
i don't be bullying anybody i didn't
bully anybody so there's another uh dj
in la that's on the radio
his name may or may not rhyme with
fussed incredible
and uh
wow
he commented under my friend's post like
eyes
and i replied and said stop playing get
my man up there he's crazy
and somebody violate someone reported
that as bullying i'm not saying it was
fussed incredible but i'm not saying it
wasn't him bro that's crazy yeah i'm
like what the [ __ ] instagram y'all gotta
like light up punch man no it's [ __ ]
crazy tick tock's worse
because like tik we you can't post
nothing on tick tock from this interview
because of that because because of that
so i have like
two like my my account is in terrible
standing because i've posted tick tocks
of interviews an artist is holding a
joint or something it's [ __ ] crazy
tick-tock don't play dude
they don't play china ain't playing bro
i got them babies on there them kids
yeah everybody's on it used to be that
but now i feel like it's a lot of
grown-ups on that [ __ ] all the
kids be on youtube and [ __ ] too this
should be good the little kids brought
seeing a baby work a phone like a
grown-up yeah i was like
i didn't even know how to use a phone
when i was that age
so how long have you been making music
like four years fairly new to five years
four or five years fairly new to like
being a professional or a
semi-professional artist right taking it
seriously for sure
i've been taking it serious but
coming to a different level right
people pay attention yeah starting to
make really kind of understand like the
business a bit
yeah well like because i i don't even
remember how i first heard of you
i know people have shouted like i know
roddy shouted you out during our
interview for sure um
but i
[ __ ] i don't remember who put who put me
on to you bro but
it was at least a year ago
probably over a year ago yeah for sure
i've been i've been dropping music since
2019. for people who haven't heard your
[ __ ] what would you kind of like
style-wise
how would you describe what you do and
and because i feel like what you do is
kind of much needed in la because i feel
like
you make music that i can hear
crossing across the country as to where
some la [ __ ] like this [ __ ] is great
i don't know if it's gonna work
everywhere but it's it's fire
you to me you got the sound that can
work
[ __ ] wherever for sure but i'm um
i'm gonna tell you the key on that
the the blueprint why how come up with
that type of music is i listen to a lot
of old school music mm-hmm
like
like anita baker aretha franklin classic
[ __ ] like um the eisley brothers we cry
together oh yeah uh luther vandross like
i don't like i listen to
our music today young right you feel me
but
i listen to like my mom used to be in
the car this to the brats
listening to shot a right right
listening to you feel me i can't help
but like
just grab to keisha cole you feel me so
me coming up i always just had a feel
for music like r b
so and i went and i knew how to rap
right you know what i'm saying i'm i'm
i'm in the streets i got my friends we
freestyle rapping and all that but
really i love r b though i love the the
singing and i love the slow music so i
was like [ __ ]
every the the concept to be big in this
industry and to be seen is to be
different you feel me so i'm like why
not try to compare to both let me let me
try to sing and rap
and put my story together and see how i
come out i think this would work and i
and i always stood on that i remember
when i first tried to do this
somebody was trying to tell me like nah
you should just rap right but i'm like
nah this is what i want to do and i feel
it in my heart like i feel like this is
this is going to come out good i just
need the right engineer i need to write
you know what i'm saying yeah
spaceship you need all that yeah i
wasn't in that spaceship so
i had to stop really like
putting my all into these streets and
just let me start networking with
different people let me start actually
going to these studios with people let
me start introducing myself and showing
different people that i really want to
do this i'm talented i could do this
just give me a little shot and i'm gonna
show you you feel me and then that's
just how that really just came to a part
what up we gotta stop the interview real
quick um to tell you about our good
folks at blue chew don't forget man
right now you get a whole month of blue
chew
for free
that's right fellas you're dealing with
that erectile dysfunction maybe you're
under some stress some anxiety maybe
your man ain't working the way it's
supposed to
listen blue chew got you same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis uh but
it goes straight to your doorstep
indiscreet packaging uh no doctor's
appointments where you gotta go show up
to the doctor's office and have some
awkward conversation about why you're
cocky ain't up the bar but no sir all
online go to bluechu.com use the promo
code bootleg that's bluechu.com
promo code
bootleg use the promo code for me it
helps us out all right go do that and
tell me how your dick is i'll take dm
just don't send me a picture of it cause
that will get you blocked bud do you
feel like uh when you decided to kind of
take your focus off out of the streets
and like put more of like your efforts
just into music did you notice the
difference in terms of just like your
return on investment of your time
because like obviously
you know i always tell artists if you
got one foot in one foot out that's cool
if i get it everybody got to pay bills
you got to do your thing like i totally
get it
but at the same time like if you really
are going to do this music [ __ ] you got
to be 10 toes in bro like
i made this decision that
that i was gonna leave these streets
alone and really just like
i'm finna dive
real real deep into this [ __ ] and go
serious with my careers at the end of
the day this is my life you feel me it
ain't the homie's life it ain't
the jail life it ain't the pen in life
it's me you hear me so
it's like i was talking when i when i
was sitting in the county jail i was
talking to myself literally like in the
release tank going home i was talking to
myself like them
see what you're gonna do
feel me you only got two options out
this [ __ ] you don't die you're gonna go
to the pen you do this rap [ __ ]
you're gonna make your family proud
you're gonna have successful with
yourself
more people gonna wanna attach to you
you feel me hang around you [ __ ] with
you all that
so i'm like
[ __ ] it i'm finna go team with this [ __ ]
dude
i was gonna say how many times were you
locked up i'm in jail like
four times never prison though no yeah i
heard county jail supposed to be crazy
out here i've obviously i've never been
i've only been to jail in arizona
but uh
county jail in l.a i heard it's wild
yeah county jail for sure
like these young [ __ ] out here that
want to just gang banging
you know so i heard you could like be
beefing with someone in the county jail
but then if you end up in prison on the
same yard with them you guys are you
guys got him and that's functioning
that's what really made me make the
decision to just go ahead with this
music because it's like bro
you're gonna go to the pen money we're
gonna be talking just like we're gonna
be friends anyway because we gotta roll
together and and they're gonna be
talking to you just how we talking right
right there's no point i might as well
go home and go get my bag and get
serious with this [ __ ] with my life you
feel me i'm taking l after l at the l
coming back starting over for what
when i got a whole talented gift every
time you get out of jail it's like you
got to restart right you're going back
to zero you feel me yeah [ __ ] and you're
like you can't get that time back man
then you young going to jail so it's
just like come on a lot of people ain't
going to want to deal with you
it's just like you just a jailbird and
i'm that's not what i'm trying to be
labeled as i'm trying to beat up with
a successful black man coming from out
of compton you feel me that's putting on
for his community and
giving back and doing good music that's
going global around the world where
other people that's coming from my
section just not even confidence la
period can
can motivate off that like damn i
already know him right you feel me he
really come from that he really made a
decision with his life to leave that
[ __ ] alone and just get his bag and get
his money and everybody don't got to be
a rapper everybody don't got to be an
artist it's we need some black lawyers
out here we need black firefighters
policemen
you feel me we need all that going on so
it's just like we need to we need this
new family i just feel like somebody got
to start
something do you feel like that
because i do think that
to a certain extent like if you're like
a young black kid growing up in compton
you really look at ballplayers and
rappers yeah you know what i'm saying do
you feel like there's just like not that
there is that representation but do you
feel like it's just not being pushed in
enough
it ain't it it's being pushed enough but
it's like
i i'm not gonna blame it on the og's you
know and then
i can't say that because it's some oh
jesus
really ain't
guiding that young [ __ ] to do nothing
or that young homies to do anything it's
just like
you really gotta want it for yourself
bro right you feel me only you want no
other grown man telling you what to do
anyway you feel me so just like you
would want this for yourself you should
just
get up get to the grind keep your find
something productive to do instead of
being
you know what i'm saying trying to rob
somebody trying to go
end up in the independent for what when
you know you can put that energy in your
mind and that and that in the thoughts
that you had on that on that sale or on
that robbery you could have put in
something legal could have put that
money into something that helped the
whole gang to help the whole crew you
feel me i don't gotta be smart yeah
cause i mean i think that
obviously if you're wrapped up in that
life
the goal should be to get out of it
right right it should it should be at
least you know what i'm saying because
nobody wants to like like you your goal
is to like make ends meet hit your licks
as you as you can the goal is to get out
and
see everybody think is this this is what
a lot of people think in the hood is how
it's supposed to go once you make it
it's it's all right come on here here
right no that's not how it's going to go
me no
i'll find i got this business i'm going
to put on this you feel me put down and
get this blueprint going you ready to
work come on yeah you ready to work come
on
if you serious come on if not i ain't
gonna play with you you feel me you
gotta wonder for yourself because
everybody gonna get that same
opportunity it's just up to you
god put me in a position to
to to level up and put certain people on
that i know i could help it's just if
they want it for themselves because i
wanted it for myself you feel me i went
through them county jail sitting alone
when nobody was putting money on my
books but my mama and all that like i
had to go through all that i had to come
sit in them studios overnight no food
send them studios going to sleep putting
five eight songs down
some some nights i was in the studio
didn't even record i'm just there you
feel me just so i can hear good music
and just be around and be safe you feel
me yeah it's a safe place yeah you know
yeah come on man that's real every time
i went back to the streets
back in jail
it's just like it don't make no sense
it's just pointless
i was gonna say like how how recent was
your last time you had to sit down
i didn't even sit in i just
i mean i bailed out and all right he was
in and out yeah i was saying no now that
was like the last draw for me like you
know where i'm cool cool like i'm over
it because that happened with mozzie uh
i think he was locked up in like 2013 to
14 and he was like man
that last time i was sitting down and
like the fact i was in jail and
everybody knew who i was
yeah and it's just like the last time
it's just like
i barely made it you feel me it was just
that was really god on my side it's like
secret swim time it's like it's either
an hour it's never you feel me and i was
like yeah i almost really blew it so it
was just like nah i'm cool i'm cool
i chill bro i chill i go to the studio
handle my business
chill stay out the way stay out of the
way
have you like because i feel like you
know you usually will get more hate from
where you're from than anywhere else
when you really start to pop you know
what i'm saying i'm sure do you find
yourself like
um
[Music]
do you find that to be the case
or not yet like from my section yeah
from where you're from nah like
no i don't see it like that my homies
they respect me my homies really love me
like i got a lot of support and love
from my homies big homies
people that's younger than me
they really love me like i got a homie
a.d compton a.d shout out to him my guy
man great guy
one of the most standard he gives he
give me real knowledge real real game
you feel me he and go back to speaking
on opportunities
you see where he was at he was showing
all the homies the blueprint and i was
just one of the ones that just really
fought through with it and like you know
what let me try this out let me really
take advantage of this and try to change
my life he
giving us the blueprint he's showing us
you feel me it's just we was just so
stuck in the streets and just you know
what i'm saying yeah
is like one of the most like
selfless
giving dudes i've i've known a.d for a
[ __ ] i don't even know how long it's
been at least eight years something like
that it's been a long time and i've
always just i've never gotten no bad
vibes from a.d like yeah why she watched
me grow up and there and when i first
first first started the rapping
he was like yeah bro i think you should
do this like he ain't never like he
never ever told me i should not rap no i
don't think he always told me go ahead
do that yeah i've seen him i see him
showing you love on no jumper all the
time it's good it's great to see him do
like yeah if you've known ad you know
how much of a personality he's always
been on the real
like bro this is exactly what you should
be doing talking your [ __ ] and he got
the podcast going and all that community
[ __ ] is fine for sure shout out to pun
shot yes for sure i [ __ ] with pun too
it's hard to pun like even he when he
first heard me he was just like yeah you
got it bro even though he's a trash ass
rams fan
i'm a cardinal fan
oh yeah yeah yeah i love punk puns my
guy right now uh now that's what's up so
so obviously um
you just put out a new record with a new
video uh video's crazy right what is
your situation right now you straight
independent
yeah i know straight independent you had
to think about that no i ain't anything
about nintendo i don't know the way you
the way you look down he was like yeah
hey we got to stop the interview real
quick tell you about our good folks at
odd socks uh listen go to
oddssoxofficial.com they're presenting
sponsor of the bootleg kit podcast when
you go on there use the promo code
bootleg cab all one word together
bootleg kev
and you're going to get 20 off your
entire odd socks order they got all the
crazy licenses my g they got the basics
they got the twizzlers the warhead
underwear how about these these are
godfather draws you know i'm saying
shout out to the bootleg kev socks
we're gonna be dropping some merch
and if you buy the merch you get free
socks that's coming shortly uh but yo
oddssocksofficial.com
the most comfortable socks in the world
the craziest licenses they got some big
ones coming down the pipeline i can't
talk about but they just did drop
doritos and uh
[ __ ] cheetos and all that good [ __ ]
uh so listen go to oddssoxofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg cap save 20
off today go do that let's get back to
the interview what's some game that
mustard has given you because he's kind
of been through a lot of like
portions of the music business starting
off as a dj starting off kind of being
like yg's a little homie low-key you
know what i'm saying and then becoming
like one of the most prolific producers
of all time like i'm sure he's got some
great knowledge he could share no not
like i'm gonna keep with the honey like
we really had no like just sit down
conversation like that right but
it's it's like what's up i see what you
got going on like you fly you on your
[ __ ] like you know what i'm saying keep
going keep running don't stop you feel
me like and that's that's all i really
need because i know he a busy person at
the end of the day and we tapped in
we're around the same people so it's
just like i'm just grinding i ain't
really like oh no
you know recognition for him right now
nothing like that it's just he see me we
shake hands with respect i see video
hard he spin my music vegas spin it
they're wrong he showed me real love
like
it's just he's seen me grinding so we
just you know we just out of space right
now i didn't even like that have you and
roddy chopped it up at all no not yet
but he's obviously you're on his radar
he's from he's from the same city yeah
he typed in for sure for sure but i had
no conversation with him yet also like
you and roddy two kind of you know
obviously both kind of singer slash
rappers in terms of just like you know
vibes like yeah for sure we got the same
vibe like he coming from the we come
from like the same part of the
section of compton like he on the west
side of london i'm on the west side of
london his hood is just up mine's down
you feel me just we know the same people
it's all the same it's all love you feel
me he grinding i'm grinding when we meet
it's going to be up yeah 100 makes sense
for sure for sure the 7x in your name
seven times
what does that represent say this seven
times to your face you feel me just
that's what it means it's just really i
just really put the seven times on it so
people can understand what cfd means a
lot of people really don't maybe asking
me like a lot of people
don't know [ __ ] spanish like that
they're like what does that mean so i
just put this seven times on the end so
they could really understand like
see if they seven times like
say it seven times so you can understand
what's the worst pronunciation of your
name you've heard like where someone
just totally botched the whole show
[Music]
set day set a7x yeah
like what what is that like what the
[ __ ] is that siete from
what uh you know obviously
la's kind of a in a great place
musically right now i feel like
everybody's super active right now from
the ogs like games got an album coming
out the younger generation is going
[ __ ] stupid guys like yourself sure
ruchi i mean going around you too the
whole uh city is is just kalyn was just
here yesterday his album is out um
what like fan wise who are you a fan of
in the city that you're just you're just
appreciating what they're doing
um i [ __ ] ruchi for sure great guy
john fuckaruchi um
rj for show he i'm hearing he's working
on something oh you guys crazy [ __ ] you
should get some he's one of my favorite
performers yeah for sure live rj is a
movie yeah for sure um rj um
i'll be [ __ ] mozzie
um
free mozzie
um
there ain't really too many people i
really need this
like it'd be underground a lot like
femi i focus i'll be third savvy's fire
yeah some dirt fire um be super fire
i'm glad jason cash [ __ ] cash shout
out to carson daddy fire he's crazy his
album is crazy read the room is fire for
sure
and he's a good dude man shout out to
him man shot jason cash oh
yeah there's plenty more i know i got a
couple one big side
for the big sad baby stronger brothers
maybe some girl's heart for sure what do
you think it is about compton that uh
breeds like just
monster i mean think about [ __ ]
kendrick lamar game yeah
kendrick
yeah like the kendrick almas
you know what's crazy about the kendrick
album is it just kendrick album is hard
it gets better every time you listen to
it though there's not a lot of projects
like that it's like every time i listen
to the kendrick i like it more and more
and more and more and more it's like
a lot of people won't like it because
they don't really understand i'm
confident so i understand the struggle
and the pain and and the
and the deliverance delivery and
everything and i don't like how people
acting like there's not bangers on there
though bangers i'm like bro rich spirit
is [ __ ] someone what
this [ __ ] with black is just playing it
the [ __ ] um the uh
what's the record with [ __ ] uh
baby keem
uh savior that [ __ ] is hard baby keem
fire too baby keems crazy from vegas
yeah like that's i think that's
kendrick's guys it's because yeah hey
freeze fire
i just i'm listening all type of [ __ ]
bro is that anybody from td top tapping
with you top 10 with you rather pause no
more
yeah i know some of my people they [ __ ]
with absolutely absolutely's a good guy
is there a album project mixtape come in
what's next obviously
i got tape coming but i'm working on it
right now it's
it's done but i ain't really like
official
you know i ain't really like certified
certain songs and all that but it's
definitely straight independent yes
i've been [ __ ] with empire though
well you know i work in him i [ __ ] with
jim park gentry he's my guy
shout out to empire so you're doing
destroyed through empire um yeah it's a
good place that's like a great place
especially for and gentry is a [ __ ]
great guy yeah i [ __ ] images ever
since i first met him he'd been the vibe
shout out to liam that's my manager he
he introduced me to james gentry solid
yeah and i feel like empires they really
like understand the west coast [ __ ] lay
[ __ ] you know they got a lot like baby
stone gorillas and
yellow
and like you know what that's why i was
telling um
i told that to your manager about rj i
was like man
we win three almost it feels like
[ __ ] five years we wait like three
years for a [ __ ] rj album right to me
rj's the most consistent like rj to me
don't i've never heard no wack [ __ ] from
rj
so i already know this new album is
about to be crazy but i might cap [ __ ]
fire rj you're [ __ ] independent i
need to i need a project every six
months
after this one
you know what i'm saying like you should
fire for sure so you know
chateau g perrico jupiter's doing his
thing
uh yellow hills do it yeah man shout out
to empire shout out to uh all of la uh
your new record dead wrong is out
tape on the way yeah anything else you
want to shout out or talk about that you
got going on [ __ ] just shout out to my
camp you know shout out to lemmy liam's
you know that's that's that's what makes
[ __ ] happen for a [ __ ]
um
[ __ ] you know shout out to my family
shout out to my my [ __ ] that supported
my fans you know shout out to you for
even having me on this platform of
course man i appreciate you you know
giving compton a uh uh uh
we chopped it up i felt like a while ago
about like i think i mean you went back
and forth in the dm for a little bit and
then
i don't know man you're when did you get
deleted not too long ago yeah it was the
last couple of months and it was
probably like last month yeah you gotta
get that [ __ ] back yeah i mean i'm
trying to get my [ __ ] for people who
don't know follow me how do they
actually follow you now follow me siete
7x and four underscores it's a lot of
underscores yeah man i found it and i
was like
this is this a fake page and then i saw
like what you were posting on like your
story and i was like i don't know if the
fake page would be nice to be supreme
follow me
run that thing up man write it up go
follow him go stream the new record go
watch it on youtube for sure that's
doing numbers y'all go type in dead
wrong cfa 7x type that is on all
platforms so you can't miss it i think
you go seven times when you say it out
loud i just think it's catchier seven
times she had a seven times seven he
said they seven times i think that
sounds i think that's
kids like the seven times i like it i
feel like 7x is just you know it feels
like no i'm just trying to get them
right so they can know you know i know
the letter somebody might spill times
you're right people are stupid as [ __ ]
feel me there it is people don't even
like you said people don't know that's
siete seven in spanish we trying to get
them right shout out to those white
people anyway uh
go follow my guy man uh go go run the
music i appreciate you pulling up
brother thank you appreciation let's go